[Musique]
déjà ces faits à base de produits
naturels genre de famille et minéraux
que ça et d'ailleurs beaucoup l'avoir
poussé à milan ac par julie barboteau
[Musique]
puis des bruits d éviter au pays des mes
shows faut pas gras cas ce sont trois
[Musique]
dimanche pas comme un droit non l'âge de
glace inquiet devant l'autre j'en fais
bien vite achevés pas lourd face à de
belles voix s'est tue pas ta douche le
matin même et tu bouges tranquille au
championnat hergé ils m'ont fait une
blague j'ai atterri dans la scène un
monde
je pensais pour les questions et tout
match aller
tpm phoenix pour condamner convient de
se doucher ici je suis resté coi sa voix
douce et bien sûr c'est benjamin qui a
été grand sauveur qui est venu m'ouvrir
assez chaud elle a quitté la grèce dans
ma barque et
préparé qu'à trois points du salut c
dans l'essonne message apparemment
jubert c'est impossible c'est assez
apprécié des jeunes pour cent mille
euros
[Musique]
je suis tellement les 10 de coeur
[Rires]
elle est avec moi j'espère que tu auras
très peur avec tout la wii c'est que
plus dangereux se colle pas trop à quoi
j'avais devant moi anthony morrow alors
t'as l'coeur franchise
[Musique]
ac et nelly cherhal est dans un état
semi était par terre à chaque fois
épicer un peu plus
[Musique]